at 5 25 on your Monday morning we have a
career day shout out to Doris Reed
Elementary School
class after class after class plopped
themselves down on the library alphabet
rug for all kinds of discussions for
kindergarteners maybe not so much into
news more conversations about just what
is a career especially when you ask for
questions and you get my mom is a chef
and it was optional dress as your career
wish day a great showing from this young
future firefighter and if you think you
know what's going on with this young
surgeon to be you're only half right
didn't get the young lady's name but
keep your eye out for this Doctor Who
says she's also going to be a comedian
all right we had some other comedians
there sticking their eight news now
stickers on their foreheads anyway a
shout out to Brianna from our promotions
Department who took those great pictures
and also talked with each class about
the many different behind the scenes
jobs at a TV station and a shout out to
all the different folks from Baristas to
Cops and who knows what else who give of
their time for career day not only a
Doris Reed but at schools all over the
valley